this is bubble buddy's fucking fucking
bubble buddies well did quite go that
route but I think we can all agree best
first date ever
right I am oval together I I think if I
were that girl I if I were Connie I'd be
grateful that I got rescued by Stephen
at the same time be like yeah we're good
I think this was an Elsa for what okay
when we got trapped at the bottom of the
ocean in a giant bubble what I like is
that they made it seem she was a little
socially awkward - she said she had no
friends she would just sort of sit alone
on the beach reading which is Lambie you
don't see that many of little kids doing
you know on their own um you know it
kind of look like a bookworm and
everything there's gonna be some girl on
an iPad what is he gonna be on the beach
literally throwing it down ago up tsking
well it's the fact that she said she had
no friends and that was like oh um
speaking of fucking bubbles I like how
the the dude at the donut shop is making
fun of Steve and I'm like I'm like dude
the kid created in the impenetrable
bubble out of his stomach you fucking do
that asshole what is this kids deal
against Steve oh that's not oh yeah it's
like the bully from Garbage Pail Kids
such a weird thing so he was like if
they were the same age maybe buddy the
kid looks like he's almost a t that it's
like I guess he's gotta be in order to
work there it's just like well is even
the Steven could blow up the fucking
Death Star and this continued bloonan
gesture you're so cool he's gonna power
convertors oh but yeah it's uh no
bullseye some more well Brenton your t60
but it's a good introduction to a
character I think is pretty obvious
we're gonna see more wasn't she in the
opening credits she's in the opening
credits you we were looking at the voice
because I swear to god it sounded like
the woman who does either Kotaro or like
the woman who does Connie from king of
the hill Oh voice sounds so familiar
and it's like oh it's it's over be a
little girl I beat ya look up her film
on Tunisia now I don't know yeah we
looked at her filmography and I'm like
it was all like sequels we didn't
recognize I'm like bit like like the
English version of Nazca the valley the
wind she was child or it's little girl
yeah yeah something called US Air
Marshal she literally was little girl Oh
drama stuff because well it's just like
you know that's got to be a voice be
purple for it no apparently not sounding
like an adult doing sounded so familiar
I thought yeah that shows off of avatar
Korra or something but uh yeah but they
get they get stuck in this bubble and
the situation gets worse and worse and
they get to the bottom of the sea of
course they like how worse it gets to
yeah when they finally sink into that
trench I'm now it's just like uncle
Oscar phobic watching like I say I lose
like I'm starting to freak out here like
yeah me too like they're gonna die like
this like this isn't great that this
bubbles air time I'm thinking no because
you're just breathing carbon dioxide by
now get these the only thing this is a
real nipping the only thing that Bob and
me and I know it's like whatever cartoon
they do stuff like this adventure time
too but they're going deeper deeper in
here and then when the bubble bursts and
a great time when they finally get along
they just pop or 100 below zero maybe
just live on the bottom no you could
have had you of the words trying to get
up and they write it and it goes up or
maybe I don't think what is the other
women come together there is the
pressure of that bubble exploding what
it killed them instantly or something -
I mean I know just lose that air
pressure than all of us in the water
closes it around you would be it's a
real mythic but it's one of those things
where it's like because it was getting
deeper and deeper I'm like I'm come with
you I was feeling a little bit of the
anxiety of like man they're just it is
getting worse and worse
how are they gonna get out is I'll be
just one of the clown's freaking out
otherwise I can't tell if this is the
adult me or the kid me freaking out
madam we laser said go with them with
the child version to be watching this
let's say in the 80s like been like ha
ha ha fun they're on the bottom of the
ocean or what I have been like this
little seven-year-old going
usually I probably want to send fog way
scarier or is that the adult me who now
knows science and it's just like oh my
god I'm sorry whatever then - oh baby
both who knows it's awesomely scary uh
but yes stuck in this bubble gets out
I'll defeats another worm thing and I
was noticing I kind noticed it before
but now I'm really paying attention
every single time they defeat a monster
Garret always takes a some sort of jewel
away from it it's like she put it away
or something
I like how they disappear in a puff of
smoke kinda like a video game character
it might be a lot of Zelda - well tix
yeah it takes away from the fact that
steven has really gone about killing all
of God's creatures I just always feel
bad some I'm like I can't do - yo worm
was just wanting to eat he got fooled by
the ring and that's sing it out like
dies under the pier and I'm like fuck's
your problem dude this is like a magical
creature serial-killer going on here I
like when he has the bracelet chasing
the bracelet give me the bracelet it's
like you know even fries got the kids
flow the fire throw the flare oh yeah
that's come to my head - I really like
ah because so many of these romances
especially in kid shows are really fours
and this one is kind of intentionally
forced because they're literally thrown
in a bubble together but I really like
you don't know what that thing is but a
lot of eights what a lot of kids at a
check a play day it's gonna be anyway
bubble we're gonna fight monsters and uh
but this our parents think we're cute
together
but what you look on the butt but the
bracelet uh you don't know what it is
and then we break Santa says you watch
this on that day Indians on the flo
stuff it's really fucking cute it's like
it's I actually Lou tell us you like
that I love our final thoughts are just
like I'm gonna die without having any
friends I'm like wow show got morose
yeah
oh those that was fucking adorable
yeah doll and it legitimately in
legitimate work it didn't feel for us it
felt like what something you would
actually kind of see
because it's not like you know it's not
something that has like stones on it or
is especially nice it's just something
you get for like a buck or something and
you wear but he's always like oh what's
your law Cellini really hold on to their
whatever and it's like borderline creepy
but not quite because he's a little boy
and so it's okay um but the fact they
held on to it it's like the really sweet
words um so yeah and again we find
another power that the gym can do and uh
yeah like I said with every sort of new
discovery we have you kind of feel like
it's building up to something and it's
won a few times we're even it's not like
lost where it's like I better know what
the fucking answers are I've despair
people add to something good even if not
or it's more like gravity falls even if
it doesn't build up to something
incredible even though gravity falls has
been coming through with Oh gravity
gravity fool enjoying it so gravity
pulls a little different i watch gravity
on us with a comedy this one I just
watched for and that there is atmosphere
in gravity falls don't get me wrong but
this one I watched more for the
atmosphere there's just it's not always
haha funny it's just there's something
hypnotic about it's kind of relaxing
yeah it just kind of like lures you into
this kind of like hypnosis like I was
just watching this past episode I'm like
did anything really happen I'm not sure
but I kind of just like zoned out there
and it felt good
yeah there's so like I don't know the
it's kind of the same feeling I got when
I was a kid watching a show and I'd be
kind of like an a half awake half asleep
face I would just like watching a show
you know just something kind of fun and
bright and colorful and there so this is
the fever dream of a no fever dreams are
terrifying this is the nyquil of kid
shows and don't become again it back you
can't put you on edge and said this is
just very relaxing very soothing even
though but enough is going on that's not
boring and it's not gonna keep showing
this is the nice ice-cold beer at the
end of the day of kids cartoon shows
yeah yes it is this is this any militar
thing this is the bowl of Lucky Charms
in the morning
there you go that would wait I want fun
ah but but it certainly is colorful
enough and pastel enough to be the bowl
of Lucky yes
um and so sweet uh what else
oh we've hit so we paid attention to the
credit since time it was a woman who
create hits so yeah I guess I guess our
thoughts last episode made sense yeah
and apparently she's involved in
Adventure Time which also makes a lot of
us I think the lessons um I don't know
what she did but I recognized the name
so there's something about and it's not
in any way like a uh yeah we're not
really researching this it'll flip out
if we don't get everything right but but
but there is something that I always
thought was kind of fun to manage me
because I always imagined the other way
too you know a woman writing like you
know a little boy growing up or
something like that you know like how
differently are the genders in writing -
because obviously men write for the
women and vice versa uh but there's
always something fun imagining like a
woman writing for a boy because it's
like you know do they just how do they
go about it is it a lot easier or is it
a lot tougher I would almost imagine
this is the reader I don't know if she's
writing every episode I haven't paid
attention and credits so that's when H&M
obviously created the show and must have
a hand in what the grand story is gonna
be again much like Adventure Time seems
like a I I mean within the tone of the
show I don't notice a huge a lot of
difference he's just he's very nerdy
that's for sure like he kind of looks
like a classic nerd character but I
can't get that much of a bead on it yet
um and I seems like a good little boy
it's okay it's just a good kid he's
surrounded by women maybe that was the
contribution it is like this definitely
dad is kind of he's in the picture but
kinda like the I don't know Center they
take center stage
I mean garnet amethyst and pearl I mean
it definitely like you're kind of
thankfully so given Zoey him of the dead
and then before he pretty quick question
how this set up where he was trying to
remember the names he's like amethyst
and rhymes with out of this Oedipus and
yeah cuz I can remember
right I remember pearl amethyst it's a
stone it's a purple stone I even when I
see it spelled out of like to complicate
um but yeah not a good after so good you
know I am really sweet really nice uh
and know how much there is to say about
this one yeah no we got no character
seems you know they're really nice to
you looking forward to find out more
about her um I like it when they do a
different you know it's obviously
nothing wrong with white people but
there's plenty of us around in American
shows I like it when they do a different
ethnicity I mean I think she's Indian I
think it's what she is I'm not sure has
kind of Indian vibe but um but I mean
clearly not just a white kid which I
always like I like mixing it up a little
bit and yeah I'm curious see what we
discover with that character and I mean
seemed like a good start I like to see
something move they're nice what do you
got against white people man you know
one of these days they're gonna get
their day in the Sun they're gonna get
the attention they deserve and I'm gonna
be there when it happens
can we I'm gonna be like live on the
good fight man man I wish I had a
confederate flag wait that's a pixie
you know never be ashamed of who you are
be ashamed of who you aren't thanks
Mandy become a Sophia's next acceptance
speech it even has another one now
everyone whatever that will camp voting
for it's like I remember those blinking
commercials I don't think so you had
your day in the Sun oh you should do a
car ad for the general leave then we
would get the Confederate flag in there
and Matthew McConaughey and I where are
we going I don't know where did you
started it by bringing up white people
sorry
white people fuck up everything little
ology the suckage of the planet yeah we
suck
oh I'm you know what I'm part guy
nothing I really
wait now let's just end it